au cours des 25 dernières années si plus
de 50 pays ont modifié leur législation
par pour faciliter l'accès des femmes à
l'avortement force est de constater que
dans de nombreuses régions du monde ce
droit est encore restreint fragile voire
inexistant en 2023 l'avortement est
autorisé sur dememande sans restriction
dans le respect d'un certain délai dans
75 pays et pour des raisons sociaux
économique dans 1 autres il est
strictement interdit dans 24 pays
autorisés seulement pour sauver la vie
de la merre dans 41 pays et seulement
pour raison de santé dans 49 pays selon
le Center repructive 41 % des femmes en
âge de procréé dans le monde vivent dans
des pays où la législation sur
l'avortement est restrictive soit près
de 700 millions de femmes
toutes les régions du monde sont
concernées par l'existence de
législation restrictive en matière de
droit à l'IVG et par l'absence de réelle
sécurisation juridique de ce droit aux
États-Unis par exemple le revirement de
jurisprudence de la Cour suprême en juin
2022 que citit notre président Dominique
Verrien a entraîné l'adoption de lois
très restrictive voire prohibitive pour
les femmes dans plusieurs États
américains ainsi l'Alabama et le
Missouri ont voté une interdiction
totale de l'avortement même en cas
d'inceste de viol ou de danger pour la
vie de la femme enceinte certains États
ont également fait adopter des
législations criminalisant toute
interruption de grossesse dès que le pou
du fettus est détectable à contrario
d'autres États tels que la Californie
ont tenu à renforcer ce droit plus
récemment l'État de l'oho a approuvé par
référendum mardi 7 novembre 2023
l'inscription du droit à l'avortement
dans sa
constitution en Amérique latine 97 % des
femmes en âge de procréé vivent dans un
état dont la législation restreint
l'accès à l'avortement d'après la
Fédération internationale pour les
droits humains on l'a vu l'avancée
historique en décembre 2020 quand
constitué la dépénalisation de
l'avortement en Argentine est
aujourd'hui menacé avec l'élection du
nouveau président argentin dimanche
dernier l'Afrique est un des continents
où les lois sont les plus restrictives
en matière de droit à l'IVG et certains
États africains ont adopté des lois
criminalisant le recours à l'avortement
chaque année 6,2 millions d'avortements
à risque sont ainsi pratiqué en Afrique
subsaharienne causant au moins 15000
décès même en Europe ce droit reste
menacé et s'applique de façon très
hétérogène